it happened early morning when the city
was still asleep several missiles struck
zapurija bringing down two residential
buildings in a matter of seconds lives
shattered Memories of a lifetime buried
under the rubble
I was later rescue workers are still
trying to find bodies through the toxic
fumes
and as they continued their work
sending people an edge to Run for Cover
there were another three loud explosions
here in the city center and they sounded
very close to the places that were
targeted earlier in the day now the air
siren did not go off until after these
explosions we are told because the
Russians are using these s-300 missiles
that go undetected
it's considered one of the most
efficient anti-aircraft missile systems
Olga woke up to the sound of it
emotions come pouring out don't worry
about what's to come
Russia says it has a Nexus operation
region after a referendum illegal under
international law but it doesn't control
the regional Capital that's why it's
coming under attack say Anyan said he
they fled the Russian control part they
say the airstrikes are meant to scare
people away from the city
most of the people here are Russian
speakers President Vladimir Putin says
this war is in their name to protect
them but he couldn't protect them from
the Russian army foreign